it's opening day for Disney's brand-new
five billion dollar theme park in China
the Shanghai Disney Resort joining us
live from the park is our own Tom
Mackenzie who's there for the grand
opening so Tom I have to say I've never
opened a theme park give us a sense of
the scene what did they got planned for
today
David they had an opening ceremony then
they opened the gates to the park and
thousands of people came in there was
rain but it didn't really subdue
people's spirits in we've seen crowds
flocking to the rides and taking part in
the activities here Disney want to show
off the castle behind me it's the
biggest castle they've ever built
they've got their fastest roller coaster
they got 16 glands and this is all about
this big play for the Chinese consumer
that the CEO of Walt Disney Bob Iger has
talked about look he doesn't think
they're going to turn a profit this year
they don't think even that they're going
to get the per capita income revenue
that they get in their other parks but
this is a long-term play to expand the
brand in China and that's what Bob Iger
and the Disney team are trying to do
here David tummy as you said this is a
really important play for the Walt
Disney Company I know they've been
opening the parts up on a trial basis do
they have any sense of the consumer
response to this particular theme park
it's very interesting David they say
that 600,000 visitors took part in the
six weeks of trials that they had here
and outside the gates of the parks they
had a million people who came to the
Disney town here that's on the outskirts
of the park the demand is so big that
Bob Iger said yesterday that they're
already planning to expand it it's
already close to a thousand acres in
size but it's the demand that's key here
they don't think the spending is going
to be as high amongst Chinese consumers
as that is in the US for example but
they think that there are 330 million
people who could potentially come to
this park within a three hour commute
and that's what they want to take
advantage of the prices for the tickets
are lower than in other parks but
they've got all the produce they've got
all the foods and they've got all the
merchandise they're hoping that that's
going to play a part of this and of
course they've got this film tie-up with
a local business here a local media
producer here they help that's going to
help grow the brand as well but it's a
long time but what long term play for
Walt Disney they say it's the biggest
opportunity since the opening of the
park in Florida in the 1970s David Tom
they're not going to be the only game in
town
they've got competition for Wanda they
have Six Flags coming in they've got
DreamWorks coming in are they concerned
at all about other competitors
so when we spoke to Bob Iger he said in
a word he's not concerned but you're
right there is competition and there's
very vocal strong competition from the
Chinese big player that you mentioned
there dolly and Wonder they've described
Disney as a tiger and describe
themselves as a pack of wolves they've
even said Disney should get off their
turf so they've been very aggressive in
their aggressive in that competition the
way they want to take on Disney as you
say the other us flat players are hoping
to get in here as well in fact we're
expecting 60 new resorts and parks to be
built in China by 2020 but the market
they're going for is large as well the
tourism market here is worth six hundred
billion u.s. dollars it's expected to
double by 2020 we do know that Walt
Disney has struggled in places like Hong
Kong it didn't make a profit there last
year Paris has had to be restructured
but Walt Disney think they've got the
ingredients to make this one work they
think that with their IP the strong
brands and the characters that are so
familiar with people even here in China
and the quality of the experience they
think they've raised the bar they think
that's going to be a winning formula
along with that large number of visitors
and the growing spending power of
Chinese consumers because even though
the economy is slowing here Chinese
consumers remain bullish David